they have increased chances of things
like
um you know paranoia schizophrenia and
things like this
and there seems to at least be some sort
of
correlation here between certain types
of behavior
being accentuated when you take these
kind of things and
then they're really not necessary
another they say sometimes and
this is a common mantra in western
society that oh you need to let them
make their own mistakes
no you don't you don't need to make your
own mistakes a wise man can learn
from the mistakes of someone else
[Music]
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companions
came to him and asked you know we're
dealing with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
podcast in the dunya featuring the host
of
the realist philosophical podcast in the
dunya masha allah
yusuf ponder salaam alaikum
[Music]
i made the conscious decision not to ask
it because it's so repetitive everything
they don't know
they don't know that yeah yeah yeah
they're gonna see
bro they're gonna see the first episode
in september they're gonna see
the next one probably a week or two
after that it's now july 10th
and they're probably like wow um so i
got two questions one
is your name yusuf ponders or pondering
soul because when i found you
a couple months ago i remember use of
ponders but today
i see pondering soul yeah so
so when i set up the channel i was like
i need a channel name
and so i was i went through this
creative process
writing down a bunch of words associated
with the sort of things i wanted to do
and then pondering saw was the end
result of that and then when i went to
go and make a twitter
it was like ah i can't do pondering
seoul because that's already been taken
so it's like well my name's yousef you
know pondering
ponders yusuf ponders so i made yusuf
pandas as the tag
for um my twitter and then you
subponder's just kind of stuck so like
when people
talk to me because it sounds more like a
name
um the use of ponders okay people will
call me
but the youtube channel is called
pondering soul um
and then i just i guess you should
ponder this would be my
uh islamic name although
do you mind like i don't know if this is
something you're comfortable with so
no nothing you know i'm not gonna take
it personally but your
what name were you born with yeah so
this is uh
top secret information no one's privy to
it so uh
i can tell you i don't mind but my
name's um my mum
called me sean sean sean yeah i got a
little bit of paradigm [ __ ] you know
when you like know someone you just want
one at night like a prototype in your
brain
and then you have like this identity
shift now i'm just like bro
so it's like when someone you're used to
seeing someone with glasses and then
they take the glasses off all of a
sudden and say whoa this is like a whole
new person to me who's this guy
john looks like that on a frat bro in
the pics from the early episode
if you guys know what you know then uh
you saw that picture but it got me
thinking and we were talking a lot about
nufs and controlling our desires and
yusuf alaihissalam
was a wonderful study in uh controlling
one's desires
and putting a lot first and not being so
hedonistic did that have anything to do
with you
picking that name or was it something
else no no
um although he is and this is completely
coincidental but
the story of yusuf alaikum is like one
of my favorite
um in terms of you know the stories of
the prophets
i always really really enjoy that
particular sora
um but it had nothing to do with how i
ended up with that name
um so when i took my shahada
um i used to like sort of hang about
with this
particular friend of mine and his family
are muslim
and his uncle kept asking me what's my
muslim name
i said i don't have one and i didn't
really want to change my name
um i wanted to sort of stick to
the the name that i had i didn't like
the idea of changing my name
at that time and um but they kept asking
me they kept asking me
and he was a nice guy and i liked him so
you picked my name and so he said how
about yusuf
and then i was like oh that's funny
because my middle name is
joseph um and that's my dad's name as
well
joseph and in polish joseph has said uh
yousef
my mom's polish so yusuf was like
this weird combination of my
dad's name said in a polish way
but it was like my muslim name
and uh so yeah yeah youtube sounds good
so
his family just always referred to me as
yusuf um but then whenever i spoke to
anyone else i always introduced myself
as a as sean and then
when i started the channel originally i
just wanted to sort of
keep my real name and everything like
out of the way and
just stick to this notion of um
yusuf ponders and you know the whole
personality around that
um so that sort of stuck and
grew um the way it did and so now
i feel more like a youssif than i do
as sean but my father still call me yeah
sean
we got pondering soul we got use of
ponders we got lighthouse mandarin tool
in the building
marshall yeah there's too many things
for adventure podcast okay so
i have two more questions i don't want
to spend too much time on this so
um we can blaze through it and then we
can go into some deep philosophy
inshaallah
so number one uh tell me about your
upbringing so this is just
family uh i know you were born uh you
know i think catholic you said right
yes my mum started family all from
poland
uh that started family all from scotland
um
mum's side of the family sort of farmers
you know rural areas um
and that side of the family is all like
at the council estate which i think
you'd just call
ghettos or something but like really
rough areas in glasgow
and um they were both catholic
and while i was younger my dad
i mentioned in the last one he had a
heroin problem
so he was always in and out of prison uh
eventually he passed away when i was
nine
and my mother was like the one that
worked and brought in all the money so
she was always working in restaurants
and things like that
and um i did go to a catholic school
and i was christened baptized and all of
that
and so i did learn about the catholic
faith and we used to go to sunday school
which was a polish
sunday school um which is
centered around you know learning more
and more about um
called proper catholicism uh because the
polish is sort of
heavily catholic um so yeah i had that
for a long time but then when my dad
passed away
uh we kind of just drifted away
from religion um i
to begin with became more like my
sophist so like
i remember when my dad passed um
one of the first things i was saying
when i was trying to pack my bag we were
going to scotland because we buried him
there
um i remember getting angry and then
like sort of
arguing with god and i was only nine at
the time so i was quite young but
i have a vivid memory of
being on my own in my bedroom arguing
with god and sort of being
angry and um and then sort of that mice
or theism
as i got a bit older turned into atheism
um and me my brother
we kind of grew up being able to do what
we wanted whenever we wanted so we had a
very free household mama was always at
work
person that did look after us was my
grandmother from my mother's side
um who was a little polish woman who
spoke
very little english and she suffered
from things like paranoid schizophrenia
so she was um a bit of a quirky
character
to say the least but uh so she raised
this but she um
she wasn't very she you know
what's the word um authoritative she
just let us do what we wanted she never
really told us
um what to do and so we sort of had free
reign
this is your mother uh my grandmother
grandmother okay
grandmother my grandmother my mum was
working a lot um
so my grandmother was the one who just
watched us but yeah she was
a very free spirit i would say um so she
she wasn't
really on our backs or anything and um
we used to pretty much do what we wanted
so we had this very sort of
free childhood where we got to do what
we wanted um
we used to break into things like there
was this uh warehouse near us
i think when i was in year six which
would have been
i was maybe about ten we broke into this
warehouse
and uh it was filled with alcohol and so
we
we pulled all of this alcohol out of
this warehouse and then we got all the
kids from the estate
uh onto this field and we got everyone
drunk
and uh we were all and that was everyone
like even the younger kids they were
like six seven years old
and like we just got the whole child's
population
of our local area uh drunk and then we
all went home
and then we all passed out and got
clocked by parents and grounded in this
and either but we were free enough to be
able to like
do those kind of things um during the
day
and uh yeah so that was pretty much
teenage years went to a
secular school uh high school
um i i was into like heavily into music
and smoking weed
and kind of into drinking but not much
i'd do it because like everyone around
me was doing it
but it was something that always made me
a little bit anxious i much preferred
being the sort of
stoner type um and
yeah so sort of grew up uh left school
but kept getting in trouble like i
dropped out of college twice
um just started working in restaurants
um
gardening things like that and just
working and earning money and then
spending that on things like clothes
um sparkly earrings and uh
weird haircuts with patterns i used to
get um
patterns bits into my hair you with a
cut
yeah and i had that done once every
one and a half weeks and it used to cost
like 15 pounds each time so i usually
gotta keep it fresh yeah
yeah so much money i'm getting my hair
done on that and uh
yeah i was just like obsessed with that
kind of thing used to save up a grand
and then go blast it all in the traffic
center
on like aftershave and clothes and
trying to make myself look sick
and uh i look back now it just makes me
cringe but yeah
i was dead into that was quite
materialistic um ended working in things
like call centers
for a little bit um which makes customer
service and sales and
upgrades that kind of stuff and uh i did
really well at that
ended up earning quite a lot quite early
on um but then i started getting sick of
it so i just saved up
i think it was like seven grand a summer
and and then i was like i'm gonna go
traveling
so i went traveling around asia for
about a year and a half uh
in 2012 and uh
i was supposed to visit something like
18 countries in
six months and then i ended up being
away for 18 months instead of six
instead of seeing 18 countries i only
saw i think like six or seven or eight
at the top and it's because i was just i
went somewhere and i didn't want to
leave so i just
stay there for ages you took seven grand
with you
yeah yeah favorite the last 18 a year
and a half
no way i mean it's it's asia i could see
that happen bro
well not just that like i lived like a
hobo
like i was honestly i might even be able
to find some pictures
but um like i i was living like
i was happy to live like an absolute
scruff
so um in korea so that was the first
place we went to
we went and we stayed in a temple a
buddhist temple and we didn't have to
spend anything there all we had to do
was work on the farm
um so we didn't spend any money for two
weeks at all
so we were there working on farms they
were feeding us and we had somewhere to
stay
um and then when we left there we did
things like we went and
we found a public park in the middle of
seoul in korea
um and we there was this like utility
building in the middle of the public
park
and we climbed up on the roof and we got
cardboard and we made like a little
hobo tent and we slept on a roof in the
middle of a park
and then we got woke up by the rain in
the morning and so we got off and or
we'd sleep on benches
on top of hills or something or um
and then we did things like when i got
to taiwan we were couch surfing
which is like a traveler's social media
where people
will let you stay in the house for free
really weird concepts but it's a thing
and so we were just staying with people
and then they were showing us around and
they'd just let us crash in their house
that didn't give you a food tour you had
to pay for that uh etiquette is you'd
bring them food
you don't it's not the case and
sometimes depending on who you were with
they'd give you food if the you know if
they were doing certain people were
really nice
and certain people just loved the the
ability to engage with foreigners and
travelers
um and if they were well off they'd have
lots of food and things like that so
that was okay so sometimes she'd be
staying with things like people like
students
they didn't necessarily have the money
um but
they were interesting people and they
wanted to meet people and so you you'd
recognize
what was going on usually you'd come to
the house with like fruit
or something or you'd say this is how we
generally operate anyway we
say let's go for summit and we'll get
you we'll pay for the meal or whatever
um but some people didn't do that some
people would just
use it as like a stop and then they
would literally just sleep there and not
really spend time with the host
and then get off so we did things like
that there was one guy um we stayed with
and uh he was an old man an old american
man who
who was the king of the vegans who
bought some land
in the middle of taiwan on this mountain
i mean
[Music]
yeah this guy he just bought some london
on this mountaintop
in the jungle in taiwan and uh we went
and crashed in his and he
he said right you're staying here and
basically we had a roof
with no walls so it was like these four
posts
in the jungle on this mountain um it was
just a roof
and then the bed was like just a raised
wooden platform with a mosquito net
around it and uh and then that was like
where we were to stay
and then we were sleeping at night and
there was bats flying around
the tent and there was cicadas i don't
know if anyone knows what cicada is but
it's just this really really
really really loud insect that screams
almost and you've just got like 50 of
these around your head
in the middle of the night there was
just no sleeping without we're not
saying that and the guy turned out to be
a bit crazy as well because he lived
there on his own
um and he was like let's go get food and
so his version of let's go get food
wasn't like let's go kfc or anything
it was let's walk into the jungle and
then try and find
weird uh roots in the ground
or growths off a tree or a flower and so
he was like oh there's a banana tree
i thought i'll bust him we're gonna get
some bananas nope
we're gonna get the flour and we're
gonna eat the flour
and he basically just crushed this
banana flower thing
with some other stuff and made this goo
and he was like bon appetit
disgusting so we tried like obviously we
didn't want to be rude so we were trying
to um
like we were putting tuna in it and that
trying to make it edible
uh but it was it was horrible and uh so
yeah we didn't stay there for long but
that was free um and then when we went
to
malaysia uh we went to this island
called tiaman
and there was a woman running a bar and
she had a few chalets that were like run
down
like they run down is probably not even
a good enough word to describe the
quality of the chalets but they were
they were
really really old they were in disrepair
um
the the toilets were like constantly
dripping and leaking so the there was
loads of mold and everything in the
bathroom
uh the bed was like a million years old
and uh we had like a sheet that wasn't
even fitted and it was just you put the
sheet on top of it
and there was a fan that you turned on
and to feel the effects of the fan you
had to have like your face
pretty much right next to it but if you
turned it off you could see like
a century's worth of dead insects that
had been
chewed up by this fan and uh and then
there was just jungle just growing over
it and taking it
and uh i'll see if i can find a picture
of and
we and there was always people staying
there because we didn't have to pay so
we said
we'll help you run your bar just let us
stay in one of your crappy shallows
and so she was like yeah no problem so
she let us stay here and so we were
always having people
like sort of stay there with us and so
that rather than sleeping in the bed you
know you get a double bed
you usually sleep in it lengthways we'd
maybe have like four or five people
sleeping in it
um with ways instead of work so you can
fit more people on
um bro that reminds me of uh but i'll
tell you about that afternoon
yeah i went to uh iceland with angel who
was the third brother who couldn't make
it tonight for three muslims
and another brother and when we went to
iceland it was just supposed to be two
of us
it wasn't supposed to be three so it's
the last minute plan
and bro if you know anything about
iceland it's crazy expensive so
we booked airbnbs weeks and months in
advance
so what we did was we just we went with
three men's
and all these two bet two people
accommodations
um usually it was a double or queen i
improvised
the whip thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
bro i'm back then i used to snore a lot
apparently according to idaho you know i
don't snow anymore now but
apparently was so bad this man in the
freezing cold he would take her car keys
go to her car and then when we woke up i
would like eat breakfast you know do my
thing come in the car he's still
let me share my screen i'll show you go
for it bro i'll just quickly this is the
only surviving picture i have of this
place
um but yeah so
like on the inside it was just
absolutely shocking and when you
you can see the floor on this um
see see the floor that wood kind of
flooring that you see underneath me
that was what it was like inside of the
chalet as well um
and then we strung up these hammocks and
you can see the jungle
is like it's just pure jungle there mate
it's not
it's not like oh let's just walk through
this jungle kind of jungle it's a
no we need a machete
[Music]
you're not walking through it but it was
just yeah it was
such a like a scruffy dent
and uh but yeah we were chilled like it
was free so it just meant
the more we could live like this the
longer we could travel for and um
and we'd always eat cheap so we'd always
eat street food
like when i went myanmar um
we had the option to i was on my own at
this point but
i had the option to stay in a room and
spend a bit more
um but i was always like no no no what's
the cheapest
is that we can stay in the corridor for
three dollars and so like i would
basically sleep in the corridor of this
like hostel
um next to a few other people who also
wanted to
travel cheap so they'd be sleeping in
the cover
outside of people's rooms and um and
then you'd go for food and you'd find
like it's like a back alley like an
alleyway or like and
someone had made a restaurant um and
this restaurant was basically
some stones next to the curb
uh with a fire and then a pop on top of
stones on a fire
next to mexical curb you know like in a
cutter in a back alley
um and then the tables were just like
buckets that are turned upside down
and the chairs were the same buckets
turned upside down
so just like basically tables and chairs
was just
upside down food buckets or like all
your buckets whatever
and uh and then yeah and you'd spend
like a couple of dollars
to get like a huge scram that someone's
made in some alley
um on a fire next to the curb so there
was definitely no daughter
in the picture back then no no
definitely not because there's no you're
not doing this bro with the daughter in
the picture
i'd probably not i wouldn't do that i'd
probably
still be a bit hobo
i just i'd obviously be conscious of
keeping her safe so i'd try to be a bit
more
careful whereas with me it was like i
was quite
happy just sleeping in really weird
places
which looking back now was probably
quite dangerous
um a few times uh but i don't know
young stupid uh like
in love with this idea of the adventure
lifestyle
um what's up what's the takeaway like
one big lesson if you had to only pick
one i know there was tons of things you
probably picked up on but
one main piece of wisdom from this nomad
lifestyle
uh it's like peter pan man
the never neverland it's this attempt to
not really grow up
and it's you know they sell it quite
well i can sell it quite well i can tell
you about all these amazing stories
um but it's never like that like it's
it's intense it's um it's wrapped up
with some of the biggest sort of amazing
experiences
like constant sequences of
the feeling of all almost like every
week
um to feelings of
severe depression um
it was just an up and down up and down
up and down and
uh it's a really weird way to live
because like when you get bored you move
on you go somewhere else you check
someone else out
you you're doing mad stuff like you're
eating scorpions one minute or
like you're eating mystery meat you
later find out after
the fact turned out to be like dog or
something
weird and it's like oh well i probably
wouldn't have eaten that
i don't know i don't know it was a dog
um
to yeah just mad things like this that
island
um to that forward that i showed you
that was team one island
beautiful place fell in love with it i
lived there for about eight months
i ended up um that particular bar was a
i think a norwegian woman's bar um
and the second time i went i worked
at another bar um which i ended up
running rather than
basically i paid rent to the guy who
owned the dive shop
and then we ran this bar and um
that was mad because it was like
i was a full-time resident in this place
pretty much and if i'd
if i needed to leave it'd be once every
three months from beats it was running
out
and i've come back but this place was
like paradise and that was probably
the major thing that one made me want to
stay there because it was like we lived
on a beach you woke up in the morning
you just jump off the jetty
into the ocean and it took two minutes
to get into the ocean and that was the
wake up
sort of thing and it's beautiful clear
waters you've got all these mad fish
turtles and that
um and just crystal clear water
beautiful um but there was a lot of mad
things going on on the island people had
bad drug addictions so there's people
and you know
these are people that i would talk to
like the youth right about my age
um really good lads get on with them and
then they'd just be like in my toilet
doing heroin
and then you'd be like what are you
doing and they would talk about
heroin like it was like nothing yeah
like cereal yeah
yeah like it was niche it's like bro
that's not a good thing to be doing now
why are you doing that
but they couldn't get it um obviously i
had a particular experience because my
dad
which made me see it in a very sort of
particular way
um but it was just really weird to see
them not
have that same experience at all it was
like it was nothing
um and there was all the lads that were
like on meth
oh yeah like let me ask you this and
once again bro i'm gonna remind you
anything you don't want to talk about
just
i'm not gonna take a person what made
you quit
this weed was it more islam or
was it kind of before that you were
already like outgrowing that yeah
so i'd been smoking it
on and off since i was about 12.
mostly on very little time off
um so and it became like a huge part of
my life
for a very very very long time um
[Music]
i was like a heavy advocate for it like
i
really thought that it was going to like
solve all the world's problems
um and i used to pride myself in being
able to make what i refer to as super
suits
um which are basically like you'd get
loads of rizzler and
put them together and i was really
really really good at making big
ones which was good for communal
smoking um which came in
real handy when i was traveling um
because it was always like a really good
icebreaker nearly everyone smoked
and so you would just be like oh i could
make a super suit and you'd just make
this stupidly
large um smoking thing all right
um there was this other one called it
was like a cross
joint yeah um
i could make them i just used to make
all these like fancy things and i loved
it and it was like a really
big part of my life for a long time and
uh
it was difficult to sort of give it up
when i got back from traveling i still
loved it
um and
i like but i was starting to hate it
because like it got to a point where it
was like every day all day
i would wake up in the morning um the
first thing i would do is like
hit a bong or like smoke something or
like it was just
there wasn't it felt like there wasn't
really a moment i wasn't
stoned out mad and then being sober was
weird
because i was happy it was boring yeah
and it was spending too it was just
costing too much
it was like weeds really really
expensive it's like for
like a 20 pound you're getting like 1.8
1.9 gram and if you're buying it in a
larger amount
you're spending like upwards to maybe
200 to 250 pounds for an ounce of weed
which is just
extortionate um so yeah it was just it
was costing me too much money
and it was just taking too much time and
i was going through
about 3.5 grams of it a day
um which is a lot of money's
and uh yeah it just got to a point where
i was like i need to quit
but it was hard so what i did is i just
sort of
reduced my usage a lot um and i moved
out and i
stopped hanging about with a lot of
people that was doing that kind of thing
and i took my chihuahua at this point um
but i was still
smoking for a while because it was
really really really difficult to let go
off
and like i was quite isolated and it was
um something i used quite a lot to sort
of help manage my anxieties
um so i kept smoking it for a bit and
then um
eventually with my wife i found out that
um
she was pregnant and the news of the
daughter
was it oh that was it then never touched
it again
and then not just weed i stopped smoking
i like
just finding out i was going to be a dad
you never would work
never know you feel like a lot i don't
want to say like that's why
you have a daughter but it's almost like
it was a perfect time
to like you know everything happened in
his brother to like get you to
abstain yeah yeah well it was definitely
like
a key moment like i'd been battling on
and off
even just like smoking so it was weird
because i
there was a period where i used to smoke
cigarettes and
then i would also smoke weed and so i
saw myself as a someone who smoked
cigarettes
and smoke weed eventually i'd give up
cigarettes
but then i still smoke weed and no
matter what
it was like weed was something really
difficult to lay off because it was also
really social element
of my life it was um something that was
really easy to sort of everyone i knew
smoked it everyone or everyone around me
was always smoking it um it's always
like the first thing
why don't you come around and we'll do
this and we'll watch some funny movies
and so we just
like be idiots and get stolen and watch
stupid stuff
you never had any like bad trips uh yes
yes i did of course
those didn't make you want to quit uh
no but it was it was it was the end all
where it was like it just happened right
where you you chose to humble yourself
before allah
you know yeah so it's just
you know what it was the the news of a
daughter was like i've got to sort
myself out i've got
grown up now i can't be no muppet like
you know i'm not going to be and just
the thought of
her being around that kind of thing just
not me sick
like it was like i don't want to be a
dad
that smokes around my daughter i don't
want to be a dad that has to go off and
sneak
and hide to smoke and then come back
stinking
or like i don't want to be having a
daughter
a baby around me and me being stoned or
me being wanting to be stoned or even if
like because
a baby's a 24 7 thing man like they're
they're waking up throughout the night
they're always needing your help there's
no
oh let me get stoned and
not have to like deal with the baby like
there's no opportunity
like if you if you're getting stoned
what you're going to end up doing is
you're going to have to deal with the
baby while you're high
and the thought of have ever doing that
was like no
no i ain't doing that um
so yeah just gave it up never and
the urge has left as well like even the
thought of smoking now
knocks me sick and um
if i've ever been around like some of
the old friends i used to hang about or
like my brother or anything
they all still smoke and the smell of it
just makes me feel uneasy like i can't
i know if i ever touched it again i go
absolutely underpants
that's the reason that weed is hard to
quit for for a lot of
drugs and you know substances they're
they're physiologically addicting but
wheat is psychologically addicting
and yeah it's a very difficult thing to
break that pattern but we always used to
go on about that as well we were like no
weed's not even addictive
and it's like cool whenever i want yeah
yeah and it's like oh i can stop
tomorrow then oh then why don't you stop
oh cause i don't need to stop don't
worry i don't wanna
why don't you go a week without it uh
that's when that's when you you know
you're hooked
yeah yeah and um yeah so
alhamdulillah that's just not part of my
life at all anymore and
i don't want it to be but it was for
like but by the time i'd quit
at that point i had been smoking weed
more more most of my life than i had not
been
so i think i quit when i was like 25 or
something so i'd been smoking weed for
like 13 years
and there'd been 12 years of my life
where i hadn't
so you know at that point it was like
i'd gone past this
threshold it was like that's a long time
to stop reading
i don't want to be an old old man
going on about guys how bad was your
anxieties and all that
pretty bad like uh
severe anxiety so they did this test
thing on me
um where they ask you questions and you
go
and you speak to professionals and that
and then like they have this graph
or this thing and it's like from 0 to 10
you're a nine i was like okay that
sounds
pretty bad um see i was
super super super severely anxious
all the time and i still am like to a
degree i always feel anxious
and um it's never really left me but
it's not as extreme or it's not as
severe as it used to be
but i think that we'd probably really
played a game
or did it take it away well it was it
was
a form of escapism so it was it was a
method of
avoiding certain things in life
it made me very complacent and lazy
um and the the sort of behaviors that
i'd associated with it
um were just like i'd
sort of lose myself a bit and it was it
was a way of
just getting me to relax and this was
how i would relax
and if i wanted to relax if i needed to
relax that's how i would do it
um like when i was when i started
studying
um the first year that i was studying i
was still doing it
and i remember i used to like i'd finish
uh class and i used to study in the city
center so i had to mission for like an
hour to get home
going on like you know i'd walk for half
an hour and then get a tram
and then that'd take me to my girl and
um
i remember like even just on my way home
being so anxious thinking i need to go
home i need to bring my drug dealer
that makes me anxious because they were
always so dodgy they'd always say like
yeah i'll be there in five minutes
and then they'd be there like 10 hours
later and then always worrying about
whether or not they were gonna sell you
short
so i always had to like get anxious to
make sure that it weighed
what it was supposed to weigh and then
trying to split it and
like map the evening out how and that
whole process just used to make me
anxious
and like i remember power walking home
because i needed to get back and
that i needed to relax um and that was
the way i would do it
through a whole different lifestyle yeah
yeah
and then um yeah just finding out you
got a daughter on the way was
like left that knocked it on the head
and then
i chilled out like it just helps me so
much
leaving that behind and um getting
some responsibility like becoming an
adult having something that is utterly
dependent upon
you um obviously it doesn't work for
everyone i think some people
um my dad being a good example of that
that didn't seem to
help him sort of get on track i guess
but yeah for me it was just that was a a
key
moment in my life it was like enough is
enough kind of like a wake-up call
yeah yeah what's what's a parallel you
can you can depict between
nihilism and substances if there's any
so there can be um so the thing is with
nihilism is when someone's
experiencing it um
what is what is nihilism for a lot of
people because a lot of viewers
there's like what is that term nihilism
is
in short it's just the the idea that
life and existence
and the cosmos as a whole everything
is utterly meaningless and insignificant
and you you get a sense of this at some
point
i think in your life everyone does
when you
sort of embedded in a hedonistic
lifestyle of sorts
usually in teenage years you know you
you become obsessed with certain things
women money
cars clothes power this certain other
and um
you sort of just dive into it
and you you keep trying to
like sort of achieve this disney prince
sort of you know the happy ending sort
of life and you're like yeah i need
i need to become rich i need to do this
i need to
have you know i need people to respect
me or whatever and so you try to pursue
a lifestyle
um and you're seeking these pleasures
but then eventually they just like
you're seeking them but they're not
really even giving you any pleasure
anymore not only that
they're even causing you pain some of
these things
and um and when you do engaging them
like
you've got this huge urge to engage in
it
um because this hyper desire
but then when you attain it there's like
it feels hollow it feels
like it didn't live up to the hype it
feels
empty and when your life revolves around
these type of things
life begins to start to feel empty as
well um
and you see the the uselessness of it or
you start to see the falsity in that
kind of life you see this isn't
this isn't why i'm here this isn't what
life is about
um this is stupid this is silly
um and it you know some people don't see
that
um and they get sort of stuck in it and
then
you need to sort of deal with some sort
of escapism
now oddly enough some people will just
sort of engage in the same
sort of behaviors that cause the
feelings
um and then they just get stuck in this
nasty feedback loop
where they keep sort of they get deeper
into it yeah deeper and deeper and
deeper into the
the different avenues of holes be that
with women or drugs or
alcohol or computer games
or the online world or whatever it is
you know there's many different avenues
but it's just it's a form of escapism
that you recognize that the universe is
meaningless or empty
a void of significance so you try to
escape it and you try to jump into
something in order to avoid that
is there a line though between um
consciously realizing that life is
meaningless and unconsciously just
living in that way
or is it kind of blurred and just a mesh
repeat the question so i'm saying in for
someone who's like a nihilist just like
losing losing and living that lifestyle
is there this mental i guess separation
between a conscious understanding that
okay life is meaningless
and the unconscious i guess presence of
being in that state
okay good question does it just mesh
so i think for the majority of people
it's not a conscious decision
it's just like a smell it's in the air
it's just something you're feeling the
presence of
and you can be aware of it but it's it's
quite terrifying
um and so you want to avoid it
but it's it's not like oh i don't you
know i'm a nihilist
people people half the time don't even
know what the word means
um and it's it's not necessarily a
conversation they'll even have
unless they're in one of the lowest
moments um
or in therapy or something yeah exactly
but you know so they'll just avoid it
and they'll try to stay positive and if
you ever try to start to have
serious conversations like i was always
a bit of um
a quote-unquote buzzkill i guess
sometimes where like everyone would be
having this particular
sort of night where they're just you
know
small talk or getting drunk and talking
silly
about random things um and then i'd be
like wanting to talk about
death or like you know
impending doom or yeah
death in the sense like what you know
life what's what's the meaning of life
or conspiracy theories like what
what's this what's going on here um
and i get i don't know maybe because i'd
sort of experience quite a lot of death
growing up i was already really exposed
to it and it didn't
strike me as strange or um
as it struck me as an important subject
and it was always weird that
people weren't as willing to talk about
these things um
or as interested to talk about these
things as i was
um but yeah i think
that either people are recognizing it
because
as far as i see it nihilism is sort of a
societal problem at the moment
it's not like just a philosophy people
are picking it's a necessary consequence
of particular
set of values um and at the moment in
western society
the values are very
particular and they sort of accentuate
this this feeling of nihilism
and you know you've got this um
pervading feeling or this like dark
cloud that's above
everyone and they're just sort of trying
to escape it because
people generally in western society
don't believe
anymore or they don't act like they
believe at least
um and the life has become incredibly
animalistic to a certain degree that is
you know there's a focus on
dunyash things focus on pleasure seeking
um and this is
what causes nihilism it's like the
ultimately its foundation uh the
universe and everything in it is
is uh it's just dead matter there's no
consciousness at the bottom of it and if
there's no consciousness and there's no
you know there's nothing
being aimed at is random it's
pointless it's just ups and downs
and you're seeing good people getting
trodden on and
hurt and you're seeing bad people get
all these things you want
bad people have got the money they've
got this they've got that
um i see what i mean bro it's depressing
even hearing it so i can imagine how it
is
talking about it so it's um it's not
like
fun so to speak to study it just feels
really necessary
um but like i don't know i've always
been weird so that this
and it the experience is like
um the analogies i've always made
there's certain moments in my life where
i've had this experience of something
and the feeling that i've had in these
moments is analogous to sort of
a full realization of what nihilism is
or the experience of it
um and so there was one time i'd um
we'd done this this drug called
but it was we just bought seeds like if
you plant them they grow and they turn
into flowers
um but they were a particular kind of
seed that they had this
sort of psychedelic effect of yeah yeah
and we'd crush them
and then we'd like sieve this stuff out
of the middle of it
and then we'd put it in and we'd make a
little bomb out of it and drop it
you guys really did something that you
don't know what it is
well we we knew it was a seed like it
was like
that's not enough information for me no
we did
not looked into it a bit like we were
reading about it and it's
like i was reading experiences of what
people have had uh
what did you read just people's accounts
of their experiences
what what were they like briefly
were they good were they bad was it
something like dmp where it was like
being really cautious
yeah it was like varied it was it was
up and down there was many different
kinds of experiences so
a lot of people had like really good
experiences and a lot of people had a
really bad
one and um and i'm like hypersensitive
to these kind of things
and uh even like like whenever
whenever i took anything i was always
like the first one to be
affected by it and it it would always
like hit me
way more than it hit everyone else and
i'd like and so we we took these things
called seeds
i i can't even remember what they were
called probably the best i don't tell
you what they are anyway but
um and it just
it was really weird and i had this sort
of mad experience of the world
being very very present and like
everything was
extra sensitive so like i started
washing my hands
and then i was like even now i can
remember the experience i remember how
soft the soap was
and so i just poured loads of soap onto
my hands and i was just in my mates
bathroom just like
just experiencing the softness of soap
and then we were like me and him were
running up and down the stairs
and then he put dubstep on the summer it
was like
and i was laying his bed and it felt
like i was like on clouds and
so i go really up and then
i always come crashing so i always
felt like whenever i did anything like
this i always had this really really
high up
and then it always went down to this
like really dark scary place
and um the second time i took it i fell
into a black hole
this is the only way i can explain it is
like
i i would have loads and loads of vlogs
of wolves loads of energy
out of nowhere and so we'd run around
and we were like screaming out the
windows and like powering up like super
saiyans
and then all my energy would i would
lose it and i would feel utterly
powerless
and i would just sink to the floor and
i'd like lost control of my body
like really i'd like i lost it like i
was just laying on the floor
and then i couldn't keep my eyes open
and then all the
le all that was left of me was my
heartbeat and i was sure i was gonna die
like i felt like any moment now i'm
gonna die and i was in a
severe state of panic but i couldn't do
anything
like i was fully conscious like i was i
was there
i just i was lay on the floor my i
couldn't open my eyes
the world was dark and like it wasn't a
dream
i wasn't asleep like i was there and
then like
it felt like i had to try and crawl out
of this hole and then like
force myself to open my eyes and i was
trying to like ask my friends for help
and they were just like sat down just
talking
trying not to freak me out by acting
normal um
while i was going to some dark place
and that feeling of utter terror
of darkness of
nothing of just a heartbeat
being on my own feeling utterly
powerless
and despite having these people around
me feeling like there was
light years between us and being
ultimately alone
that was nihilism that was like
just sheer terror and because
everything else just seems like why am i
doing these things like why
who cares about that who cares about
this like when it came to it when it
came to like the moment of
feeling like you were going to die um
like things start to sort of fall into
perspective a bit
but that's what nihilism is like it's
like
realizing you're you're a finite being
that death is coming
every breath is one breath closer to the
last
every heartbeat is one beat close it's
really depressing
as you can tell it's uh no this is
listen man we
we started this whole gen series about
it right a lot of people don't we're not
experts but it's
it's essentially your your like your
your soul it's kind of like
what this is our theory again and our
bodies like our physical bodies right
where we where we are right now
our soul is kind of interwoven into it
and that's the way it should be that's
the way allah designed this to be when
you do these
these drugs and it lowers your hijab and
you're more vulnerable to
a lot of things that are from the unseen
all right
it just creates this separation from
you know your role and your physical
body now
it's all fun it feels nice but
what if you can't come back what if
you're not you don't when you do come
back you're not the same
well these things definitely change you
like i know
like whenever i did these things that
they they were always
it was terrifying i did it more than
once i don't know why
well no i don't know why um
because it it in a way it made you
really really take life seriously
and um like every time i did it it was
always
so exhausting like i couldn't like if i
ever did it it was once every couple of
years
and um no problem
um once every couple of years
and it was always hyper significant but
hyper terrifying
and now the thing is is
it's funny you mentioned jin as well
because i i have theories about
yes and it and it relates um as well to
things like
the the soul and it also relates to
these things about dmt
um so maybe we can go into that
inshallah but
yeah i i was doing it because i was
trying to find
something i was i was in search of
something and
the it was clear that whatever i was
sort of
focused on was empty it was hollow there
was nothing to it
um but there was always this sense of
something significant in place
and you could always you could always
see it but it was never
it was never in worldly pursuits it was
never
in the drugs it was never in
the women it was never in the alcohol it
was always
everything always felt like it had it
was weird because it's this
there's this conflict you've got this
experience of the world is meaningless
when you're looking at the world in
enough itself
but then simultaneously there's always
this sense of significance there's
always this sense of
plan and it was really really hard to
describe
but i always felt watched over
like i always felt um like when i was
traveling man
i got into some weird predicaments
like crazy things were happening and
like i was like i should have died then
like that
how i wanna like i
yeah subhana there was just too many
accounts of things happening where
it was like that that should have ended
very very badly i have no idea how i got
out of that
um but i always felt like there was
something
protecting me or something watching over
me it was always this weird sense
like origin i don't know
it felt like a good thing i feel like a
good presentation
um but i also had this sort of
sense of evil as well somewhere but it
was distinct they weren't the same thing
there was like
this one thing trying to call me in one
way and
there's something trying to cope with
the same thing but like a different
like thing what i'm trying to say is
what if it's not like
good or bad what if it's just they're
all bad but some could be good
you know what i mean yeah possibly
because this ties into jing because gin
have a will so some of them could be bad
for me right and they don't they don't
want you to catch on to
how they are yeah yeah exactly but um
yeah so the the nihilism thing
so linking it back to the original um
question that experience when i was in
these like
dark places it was terrifying and
i had experiences when i wasn't taking
something which was similar to that so i
was
i went scuba diving at night and i was
in the ocean
and my torch wasn't working and i was
just alone
everyone was swimming and i remember i
turned out and i looked into the
darkness of the ocean
and then i was terrified i was like i
can't see
um like my hand in front of my face it's
that dark there could be a shark
like right in front of me and i'd have
no idea until it bit me
um and it was just pure fear and there
was one part of the body telling me to
run
or swim and get out and go and then
there's another part of me that's sort
of
just watching me panic and being like no
no no stay
like i wa like i i don't know i'm weird
i wanted to
experience that fear and let myself
experience it
and then force myself to stay and to
keep experiencing
it and it just it wasn't something that
was going away
it was there but then there was this
other part of myself that wanted to sort
of stay composed
while going through that and i had
another experience like that when i was
in a graveyard
i used to go walk around in graveyards
at night and
i had a dog at the time and i
liked the night because everyone was
asleep and there's a sense of pure
silence and bliss and peace at night
especially in graveyards
and then i just got this sense that
there was something behind me and i was
terrified
and then it was like run you need to run
out of the graveyard it's dark
there's no light uh it's pitch black
there's a monster it's gonna eat your
face
and um so this is part of me wanting to
run and then
there's another part wanting me to turn
around and look to check
and then there was another part of it
that was like no no just stand still
don't run don't turn around just submit
to whatever's going on whatever's gonna
happen is gonna happen and then so i
just stood there and i was just sort of
like watching my fear
and letting it overcome me and
i'd had lots of these experiences of
like utter fear
and of sort of recognition of my
mortality
that death was possible at any moment um
and that i need to take life seriously
and
and eventually it sort of obviously when
i went traveling
and i was trying to the traveling wasn't
so much going to places it was running
away from
you know the life that i was living and
i wanted to
see what different ways of living
nowhere so i would like i said i stayed
with monks
i was looking into buddhism um and then
i was i
met a lot of atheists a lot of atheists
i met a lot of like new age hippie types
i was talking to all of them
um i was looking into um like the modern
forms of this new age religion so there
was a particular
author that i really liked was called
randas um
and so i was re i was taking these
things seriously i was trying to figure
out is there any truth in them
um and the more obviously an islam was a
part of that as well
and so i was reading the quran i read it
i think two times um
front to back before i'd actually took
my shahada uh i was looking at the life
of the prophet i was looking into
all these arguments i was watching a lot
of youtube um so i was probably watching
this was a long time ago when i was i
can guarantee if dawa and speaker's
corner and that were all
a part of that um and
it was just engaging with these
seriously and i think these moments of
the fear of death you know
is what is going to take place after
is it really nothing am i willing to
really put
all of my money on the fact that there's
nothing after life
right what do i really believe that um
because there was a point in my life
where i did but it's like do you though
why do you believe that and so i had to
start like asking these questions
what is it that makes me think atheism
is true
what is it that makes me think that um
that there isn't necessarily
a god out there and it life was quite
chaotic so i'd like
have these experiences like i mentioned
before where it's like i had this sense
of some sort of
super significance um but then they
would sort of drift
and and then i would move back into this
sort of agnostic slash atheistic
state and it was fluxing um
certain experiences then i'd become more
sort of open to this idea
and then it would drift away and i um
it's like
allah it
you're on the ship and the storm comes
all of a sudden everyone's a believer
again
yeah yeah yeah and and then once it's
done
yeah once it's done you fall back into
forgetfulness and like
i was reading the quran and it was like
i kept reading and i kept seeing myself
in it it was like and then i was reading
more and i was seeing everyone around me
in it
and and then i was like i was starting
to see that there's
wisdom in this like i know if i stop
these type of behaviors
i know this is where contentment lies i
know this is where
um peace will reside like
in submission to a lot of the things
that are being said here
and there were parallels so like when i
was
um in the buddhist temple they
did things like pray five times a day as
well funnily enough
um and they did scheduled so they you
know even go into frustration
but they had these big gold statues that
were doing it towards
of men and um and i didn't get that
and i'd speak to them and there was
these
everywhere whenever i was talking to
people there was always these like
common themes these common patterns and
when i was really young i was really
into alien
conspiracy theory stuff and
what had happened is independently of
religion while i was an atheist
the way i'd come to understand or
conceptualize aliens
was as uh not extraterrestrial was like
extra dimensional beings
um now this touch have you ever heard of
flatlanders
i heard flat earthers
nothing to do with that nothing to do
with that it's uh it's this book
uh flatland by uh edwin a abbott
and it's a romance of
a romance of many dimensions now in this
book it talks about a
flat land like it's literally a land
that's two-dimensional so it's not a 3d
place
and there's little 2d creatures that
live in flatland so there's little
squares
little triangles there's little circles
and they live in
a flat world they have no up or down
they only have forward backwards left
and right
and uh and they live in this flat world
and that's all they know they don't know
anything else
but then this three deep
three-dimensional creature comes along
and starts talking to one of them
so you can see on the cover you've got a
little flat square man
and then you've got like a sphere here
poking through his world that's not
supposed to be there
yeah so it's well it's not they've never
experienced these things necessarily and
then and it comes over it starts talking
to one of the
little flat creatures and it hears it
but it hears it as if it's coming from
inside of its own head
because he's talking from above so like
you know how um when me and you were
talking
we can only see the outside of us i
can't see your heart pumping i can't see
your lungs breathing in or out i can't
see your brain all of these things are
concealed by your skin
now in flatland the same thing applies
when
two flat creatures are seeing each other
they only see the outside the edge
and then all of the organs are on the
inside of the shape so like the heart
would be inside
the brain and everything um but when the
3d creature is above them talking to
them it's talking to their insides
and so they hear it as if it's coming
from inside their own heads
so they hear these voices and they're
saying where are you he says i'm above
you and they say where's what you mean
above
where is above they say show yourself
and so the
the 3d creature lowers himself and he
goes into their world
which you see there and what happens is
they experience this
dot appear in front of them as if out of
nowhere
and then it grows and grows as the
circle as this as the sphere
goes in obviously the closer it gets to
the center
the bigger the the shape is in that
plane
and so you've got the singapore's out of
nowhere and then grows and then
as it leaves again it shrinks and
shrinks until it disappears
and uh and they say where did you go
like how and then he's like well
i'm there's the world is more
complicated than you think it's not just
forward back
left and right there's an up and a down
as well and he says show me this up
so the the the three-dimensional
creature takes two-dimensional creature
and he takes him up
and he looks down at his world in a
completely unique way for the first time
he sees inside of people so he's looking
down
and he can see not just people's skins
he can see the bodies inside of them he
can see their hearts beating
he can see their lungs they can see the
brains it like he
he sees inside of his name his
neighbor's house
and outside of it at the same time he
sees what's in his neighbor's safe
like he sees everything and he's he's
never experienced
the world like this before and then the
3d creature drops him back
and in front of his friends and he just
appears in front of his friends it's
about nowhere
and they say well how did you do that
you've just
appeared out of thin air he says that
i've just been up
and then they're like what do you mean
up and then he's got to try and like
explain to them where he's been what
this place is but they have
like he did before he went up no way of
like really understanding what's going
on socializing even yeah
no um i
was thinking of aliens in this way
so i was thinking of
aliens if they exist this is prior to
like becoming a theist
i was thinking of um because i was
watching even carl sagan videos
carl sagan does a video on this about
where he's talking about actually
dimensions and he makes reference to
this book
he's talking about it and um and it made
sense
it's like well if there is aliens surely
it's much more likely that they'd be
extra dimensional than extraterrestrial
because
stars are just too far away like 100 and
it just if we're experiencing all of
these things
and so my alien my idea of alien became
this extra dimensional being
um that could move between dimensions
um or was an extra dimensional thing
like the circle
and i was like so you know when you hear
voices in your head when i was an
atheist i just assumed
every voice in my head was mine but it
was and then i started asking the
question well
how do i know like imagine flatlands is
real
we're the 2d creatures and there's 3d
creatures
obviously we're three-dimensional so the
the 3d creatures in the analogy they'd
be four-dimensional
so and they'd be saying no the world's
not just up down left right
forward and backwards there's another
direction
and need whatever he refers to as um
and allah writes in the quran that you
know for jin they see you from where you
you are you can't see them and bro
and this is funny because all these
things started clicking in place after
so i was thinking of aliens in this sort
of way as extra dimensional beings
um and then i was thinking about like so
what are angels what demons what what's
all this
and then it starts just the more i
looked into it
the more it felt like it was um
uh just a semantics issue like they were
all the same thing
like when people are talking about
angels and demons i was just being
pedantic
and just wanting to call them aliens and
it's like well
you know back in the day when people
would see these things
and whatever it is that's going on
things appearing out of nowhere in front
of them
um and then going away and when you're
looking when i was in the buddhist
temple as well they had
similar experiences they were talking
about this this
species of people that we have this
connection with
um yeah it's fine they lived in another
world
and the higher monk the highest monk
that lived in this temple he said he
could travel
and he he'd go there and he'd have
councils with them and they were telling
me all about this
this mad stuff and the more i was
looking into it i was looking into that
and then i was reading about
islam and i was reading about that that
what you just said there
they see you from where you cannot see
them and
uh and so then i just started like
things just started clicking in place
and the more i was looking into gin
the more it felt like gin here is is
what i've been calling aliens and what
the christians have been calling
demons and like it
just like savannah all of that started
clicking in place and
then like certain experiences started
happening as well where i was i was
starting to realize how
um there's there must be more to this
world than i think like
i had a conversation with my family i
was talking about what's your earliest
memory
and we were talking about this on a
night sorry
you were talking about what what's your
earliest memory
so it was a conversation with having and
we were in the middle of a road waiting
to the lights to turn so we could cross
and we were on our own isolated
we went about shopping four or five
hours later we went for something to eat
and we'd not been spoken speaking about
this for like four or five hours
and we were on our own when we were
talking about it and we sat down eating
and the waitress has gone to the table
behind us
and the guy started talking to her and
he said to her uh what's your earliest
memory
and bro it just sent my head west i was
like and because i was really thinking
about all this flatlander stuff
i was like what if he has seen um
my memory or my thought
about that question how would he be able
to
distinguish that from his own thoughts
there would be no way
he would have to see that thing would
popping into his head he would just
assume
oh i've just had an idea but if the
world is more complex than that if
like and this is a really common
experience that people have a lot
you you're thinking about someone and
then they ring you
like too quick for it to be a
coincidence like
and they're like oh yeah i was just
thinking about you bro i was just
thinking about
you that's weird or you're thinking
about someone and you walk around the
corner and then they're there
like there was just all of these things
and it was just
i was getting closer and closer to this
notion of the unseen
um and yeah so the more i was looking
into it
the more and more i was becoming
convinced of the
islamic paradigm in particular um
because it
even the islamic paradigm it recognizes
that there is
um overlap and all these other cultures
all these other religions they have a
root in an original
monotheism but that they developed and
went astray as time
went on and i was seeing these links of
seeing these connections
and i was reading the quran and it was
it was speaking to me
and i was i could i you can't i couldn't
shake the significance of it
like i couldn't shake this feeling that
all of this is true
and you know the the arguments i was
looking into
you know about the existence of god um
about allah being one about how he
about um you know prophethood
about muhammad salla salam about their
companions
the more i was looking into all of this
the more i was convinced that all of
this was true
um and then yeah eventually it was just
it became a really inconvenient point
where
i had to take my shahadah despite it
being like
a really weird thing to want to have to
do because it just meant completely
changing my life
um in many ways and i wasn't too
comfortable
[Music]
taking that leap a lot because like i
said there was a lot of things i was
really into at the time
and the idea of leaving those things
behind were difficult and then the idea
of all these extra responsibilities were
difficult as well
um but yeah and like
all of these things were just starting
to click in place so it was like
um the bad habits i was doing
it was starting to become quite clear
that i should stop them um
the these notions of alien or
these other things this notion of god
all of this was starting to all click in
place
um and it was clicking in place in
relation to
every other thing that i've been looking
into
um and it was just this mad experience
of like
uh you know the jigsaw puzzle sort of
coming
into completion and like the picture is
clear now you can see what it is um
yeah so it was bad
so i got a i got two things one
not really relevant second one's
relevant though but the first one how
did you find our channel
uh i was watching
how do you pronounce the brothers names
so i remember when
i don't even know i can't remember who i
remember someone was sharing
the video of him talking about cold
showers
he did i thought he was on his reverb
video that like ayura and say no no no
no this was before he reverted
he was doing a v he was doing a video
about um
cold showers what i've learned four
years or something like that yeah yeah
and i no cold showers are sick
i just really struggled taking them in
england i used to take them all the time
when i was traveling but that was easy
because it was boiling hot over there
um and i know i if i could only get
myself to take old showers in the
morning that
i know it'd have a huge positive impact
and so i was watching that video about
that and it was like i need to do that i
still haven't um but yes
i do need to and then
after that i heard he took his shahadah
and then there was another channel
um called debating truth with jan yeah
and uh angel had an interview on there
with that brother
uh jan i think i said john i think it's
pronounced young
yeah um and so he had a huge
conversation on there and so i was
listening to that and um and then from
there
i found out that he'd started a podcast
uh with but you and brother rami
and so i started watching that as well
and uh i've not seen every episode but
i was drifting in and then i saw you
were um you did an interview with my
friend of mine freed um so i was
watching that one
and in the end i just became more and
more familiar with you and so i was
watching it a bit more so that's how i
came across
the three muslims podcast so you're like
a like
one in a way uh kind of because i
remember
you when i came across you you maybe had
a couple of thousand
subs but you went you zoomed
[Music]
i mean i mean likewise i think i think i
remember what like
again when i see something i don't
really forget it right so i saw your
face
and it was like your youtube pic i think
it's like pondering so
and it's just me it was like yeah and it
was you
in a live stream i believe it was like
our first live stream
it was like really throwback i'm talking
like maybe december or january
it was a while ago and i remember seeing
you and i was like hmm and
a lot of people were commenting like i'm
from uh pondering so i'm from ponting so
or i i'm sent from pottery so and then i
clicked on your thing
i think you shared like a live stream
like a video bars and
yeah that's when i found you and started
going through your content
all right so when was that was uh
december did you say
this number it was very early on because
we we started december 11th
unless you're singing i've been
lost here for a second there oh god
again oh
you're back you keep cutting out
i've been speaking on her uh again wrote
yeah i don't want to get too into that
but i think it was sometime around 20
it was definitely in 2019 i brought up
the fact he was kind of iffy
2020 we went to iceland
and we were we were cooking uh dinner
one day because it was at an airbnb
and we uh i was just basically telling
about
bro how we've been searching and
basically when you
there's like so many so much new weight
stuff right there's like dmt entities
there's like
like spirits and kundalini and all this
nonsense bro but
i was like bro i think i think you you
can stop looking
i think i found it he's like what i'm
like oh bro i think it's a song
and like i don't know like maybe like to
people it's like oh you were born into
it you might be biased right
and i was like bro just read the quran
like i'm telling you like this is it
it's it just reaffirmed everything
already yeah
because the thing is something has to be
true now like say for example
you could say to me i was born in an
atheist society
it's like well you know what if you were
just atheists because you were born into
an atheist society
like that none of that matters that
doesn't declare the truth or falsity of
anything
because you were born into it if it is
true
whether you were born into it is
secondary you've got to ask yourself
then it's like well
like what so even if it is true you want
me to reject it
because i happen to have been born into
it right that don't make no sense
facts facts facts that's that's true man
a lot of people don't see it that way
though however
it's pretty unfortunate um when i when i
kind of
i felt that inclination to tell him like
a brother he was
he was genuinely like if you talk about
like top
five people i'm closest to or even top
three it was him so
i kind of just i naturally told him that
and he was like
we talked about it he told me how he's
puerto rican right so he's like when he
was back in puerto rico
or uh he think was his grandfather he
was talking to
and his grandfather was like nah man
there has to be a god
we're just talking about islam here and
there nothing nothing crazy but
i got stronger into my deen 2020. see
kovid
ramadan the first ramadan in 2020 that
was my
year specifically that month i i really
increased
and i think that was really when i took
a turning point right
so anyway it was after that that
he really saw a change in me along with
a lot of people
and i was like i just felt more of a
calling bro you don't
you don't get on theme and then want to
just abandon your friends
and start like new friends you want to
at least try to see if you could guide
them
try to like give them some type of of uh
insight and then it's like okay after
that you know you've done your job
if they're not gonna budge it is what it
is so i kind of told them i was like hey
man
this is it he had a lot of questions al
hamdulillah it just it was very natural
it was it was like he had that
inclination too he had a lot of
experiences with with salah
not sorry with meditation and he just
felt guided to a song it was a very
passive experience for him it wasn't so
passive for me for him it was like
he was guided he just like kept seeing
the quran in his shelf like he just
he felt that calling repeating numbers
you know what i mean so
yeah he just kept feeling it he didn't
resist it anymore
exactly pattern and he just went into it
and he he just felt it he felt waves in
his body
and his spine he had an intense
experience and
he had a lot of questions a lot of
people once they're at this stage they
still have questions
what about this common thing what about
that what about this and
some david wood video what about this um
argument or this uh you know something
about the conduct of prophet saws
anything and then alhamdulillah you know
we had a few discussions
i told him i was like well we're gonna
we're gonna talk like here and there
every now and then we started talking
like i think
four five six hours every night
consecutively at some point and
it was at that point i was like there's
no way like he's not
after all this right and then at the end
of it
you know he was ready to do a shahada um
i think he was kind of delaying it but
i'm not gonna lie like
um i'm not gonna say it was the right
decision i'm also gonna say it's the
wrong decision because again we're still
here where we are today
alhamdulillah but i was like bro what if
you want to like be the perfect muslim
because he was saying he was saying
typical stuff that most of my friends
said before reverting like oh i wanna at
least finish the quran
bro every time i heard that i was like
what are you going to do i have to read
sahih bukhari or like
it doesn't end bro right it's like if
you feel it you could become learned but
it's like that that line of
becoming where you are you're never
going to get there so if you really feel
it
just you never know what's going to
happen right so it's error on the side
of caution so
he's like all right that i'm ready um he
became muslim alhamdulillah this was in
october of last year and as soon as we
were done
last year i also was i went to a trip to
the mountains with rami
right this is um again at this point
they still don't know each other because
when you have friends your friends might
not necessarily know each other right
so me and rami were like we should start
a podcast about islam but like
more like modern day right and we never
really
pursued it or entertained it it was just
like a something we just put out into
the universe
now after he became muslim i introduced
him to rami
because you know rami is has more
knowledge about the dean than me
and i was kind of telling them to you
know link up
and i just threw it out there man i was
like yo we should start a podcast
and angel told me this i remember he's
like
after speaking with rami it just goes to
show how far i have to go
and how much i don't know anything about
islam at least compared to him
so because of that i think we should
wait
and i'm like that's a good point because
you don't want to start you don't want
to
start you know giving dawah and trying
to you know guide people
if you don't know much but at the same
time it's like when is it
time you know so why not well i'll give
you my
sort of perception of your podcast so
for me
you've got a nice dynamic so
you know you've and it looks as if we're
sort of
going on this journey with angel like in
the process of learning and discovering
and with youtube brothers as well and
you know you
i think you bounce well off each other
so you know
100 i don't think it's a bad idea that
you you started it because
obviously you if he's you you've all got
your different perspectives
um and angel like being new into this
he's giving you the perspective of well
you know i'd like to learn about this
let's do something on it um you know
if he has his connections with um this
that or
whatever person and yourself as well um
you can obviously interact with that and
explore these questions and get answers
and
go through that process of learning with
him so it's um it's an interesting
dynamic you've got going on
that instant bro i was like bro we're
not going to be like
an islamic podcast we're going to get a
muslim podcast yeah i mean it's
different
and he's like he got that and i was like
let's just start bro like it is what it
is
um and then 100 we didn't miss a single
week i think consistency is the name of
the game
i already told them i was like this is
this is what we got to do um
we did commit to one episode a week but
we didn't really
like pick things up until we did two
episodes a week
and now we're doing three to five
uploads a week
so it's um mashallah
you so i am terrible with uh
organization so you don't get into that
impression bro is it like
it was you and um angel's videos as well
from his
uh he's got his own channel yeah bro
i'm listen i'm i'm literally no
different than anyone terrible
like you can't see my my desktop right
now i use four different apps
to just make the thumbnails because i
don't know anything i don't know ish
about
graphic design or anything i'm a med
student bro i have no experience with
like
any technical you know i'm really bad at
technology too
so video editing i didn't even know what
imovie was so the story was i
think of imovie or editing okay my movie
is like that
yeah i thought you said i amv i was like
so so i think
rami was yeah i don't mean to throw
romney under the bus but it was a funny
story arami
wanted to edit our first video because i
was like okay i'm gonna do the
thumbnails
i'm gonna do all the audio streaming
platforms patreon all that
angel is gonna try to you know post a
bit more
market a little more you know you know
whatever rami
knows more editing than all of us right
plus when we're playing call of duty bro
me and angela are just you know doing
normal people stuff this man's using
keyboard and mouse
so he's if you're a keyboard and mouse
guy you can edit the videos right so
uh it was fair enough and apparently our
little short
45 minute podcast took him i think 10 to
20 hours to just
export and i think his laptop kept
freezing or something was happening
bro it was at that time i was like nah
bro we this is not gonna work out
we can't do this every week this is this
is not how it's supposed to be
because actual file is like nothing if
if you can't edit it in right
so i got imovie on my phone bro we've we
figured some stuff out and
we just learned things along the way i
still use four different apps
for um for the thumbnails could could i
do it in one
yeah but listen for me it's it's more
like i i i found i figure out like a
self-taught way of doing something
and it's like i just stick with it i
don't want to like is there an easy way
perhaps but i'm kind of old-fashioned
like that like i have uh i do online
coaching too right for
fitness and a lot of my clients told me
you should get it calendly
all right because calendly is like where
you can book and you can it's all
automated
and then for me i'm like bro i use my
notes like my iphone notes up
and i literally put like day to day and
they're like bro how do you do that i'm
like
you just i could just erase it add
things and they're like bro
wouldn't you want calendly i downloaded
calendar libro
it to me it just seems a little more
complicated then
that's the thing when you get you see
your own patterns and that like stepping
outside of that it's just
a lot more effort sometimes 100 100
but like i was gonna suggest uh just
stream yard man
you need to get a streaming account yeah
we use it for uh
streaming and reactions we don't really
use it for recording podcasts
so you can do you can set it up unlisted
well yeah like we can record only two
with with stream ad it's just
just we just like zoom for uh for that i
don't know why
we have both okay yeah we we use we use
both so our reaction videos are
uh streaming right our live streams are
streaming too
and then our actual episodes like this
we use zoom
but i wanted to quickly uh touch on i
got like five-ish
but i'll quickly go over the theory
that me and angel came up with this was
through
i don't want to say like again we're not
we're not experts we're not
we're not anything but just people
trying to figure things out themselves
right
but this is our theory we have a theory
that
all mental illnesses right give or take
i don't want to say like
flipping alzheimer's with amyloid
plaques in your brain that's a
physiological thing
that's not just psychological at that
point right so i'm talking about most
you know psyche related psychological
disease of the mind not just like
actual things so things that are
i guess unseen they don't come up in
brain scan so anxiety depression
mild schizoaffective symptoms any type
of bipolar right these are things that
won't show
per se adhd right so our theory is
and obviously like drugs sometimes
decrease or increase these symptoms
right
so our theory is that all of these
relate to
energy right and and this is something
that's
it's pretty unconventional to today we
talk about things in a very physical way
you need drugs you need this
prescription right so energy
is just law of thermodynamics it can't
be created or destroyed
only converted from one form to another
so if energy can't be created or
destroyed we have a very
i guess abundant amount of energy
that we carry within us as as human
beings right
and the people that have these
psychological symptoms right
they just suffer and they were just born
with an excess of this energy
now this doesn't mean there's anything
wrong with them right because
the only thing making it you feel like
there's something wrong with it is
society over diagnosing and over
categorizing these mental disorders
right
they actually don't really exist in our
opinion but anyway
we're just we just we're just born with
an excess amount of energy you got adhd
that's all it is
your reticular activating system that's
the thing in your brain it's just
hyperactive
right so we have a we have a severely
high
excess amount of energy that we're not
using because today
the modern i guess man i hate to say it
but
it's what it is it's very sedentary we
live very normal
sedentary repetitive best job nine to
five lives we don't really
get up right we're just we're just in
our seats all day
and you're not using that energy so what
happens is
this energy just keeps building up kind
of like if
you have sexual energy building up right
you're not married you don't want to do
haram with yourself so you're gonna have
a wet dream
if you're just angry and you're just not
doing anything but you're not
discharging this anger
you know in a very mature and
responsible manner
or working out or something like that
you're just gonna have a
fit a rage or just flip on someone right
so similarly this this energy that we
have building inside us when we're not
using this energy right our body
just does what our body normally does
with anything
see homeostasis or equilibrium it
doesn't care how we feel
if you want to puke it doesn't it
doesn't ask you use of you're you're in
a podcast right now or you're in a
social setting maybe you might not want
to puke
it's just gonna make you want to puke
bro same with if you eat something that
you shouldn't right
so it's the same thing with this energy
it doesn't care how you feel
it just knows efficiency so the organ in
our body
that uses the most energy than anything
else
is the brain so if the brain uses more
energy than any other organ
our body just knows that if we shoot all
this excess energy to our brain
then it could just get use and just get
rid of it and use it up
if it uses it then you will be brought
back to
homeostatic or equilibrium levels of
energy where it's not
excess anymore you're at least normal
kind of like if you're
if you're too uh hot it makes you sweat
so you just get rid of the heat so in a
very same same similar way
our theory is our body just wants to get
rid of that energy
so essentially it's an invitation to to
any of the viewers right now that
you should get rid of the energy first
before your body tries to take over
in a way or like have that wet dream
analogy in a way so it's like
before it sends all this shoots all this
offset and surge of energy into your
brain
because once it does that it's too late
then then you get all these symptoms of
like an overactive brain of like brain
fog
depression anxiety adhd all this
furthermore
um what burns more calories or energy a
positive thought or a negative thought
it's obviously
a negative thought right so you combine
that
your brain's like the most efficient
machine once it gets into that feedback
of using your brain
to just get your energy levels at base
right you got two days
if the first day you spend outside
right think of it like when you were
with your with your
shabab with the boys right and you're
just out here just doing whatever
living life out here primitive just like
you're in the moment you're present
you're living life you're vibing right
how do you feel when you come home
you're good you you're exhausted you
just go to sleep like a baby right
now compare this to a day where
you're not doing that you're in your bed
thinking
about nihilistic stuff you think about
the most depressing stuff
you're over thinking and negative
thinking right
i guarantee you this you will feel more
tired
after the second day than you will after
the first day
however a lot of people think it's the
opposite right they have this
misconception that
because i'm using more energy the first
day i'll feel more tired now you will
actually feel exhausted after the second
day
because you use your brain way more
right so our invitation essentially is
do that first before your body does that
for you in a way
so this is literally what saved my
and on how's life because we used to bro
our psychological symptoms weren't like
anxiety and
we had like like depersonalization and
like de-realize there's like
really bad symptoms right and what we
started doing
normal stuff bro basketball going
outside for
a job going outside for a walk and we've
been telling
a lot of people that reach out to us and
we tell them the same thing they do it
for a couple weeks
couple months max and they feel normal
again and these are people that
haven't felt normal for years right so
any of you guys watching if you do want
any more info on what we're talking
about just hit us up on
insta or anything but essentially that's
our theory right it's not
obviously like anything yeah so this
kind of links as well
funnily enough you know when i was
talking about the flatlander's stuff
so now in the story the the 2d
creatures are only two-dimensional
um now the more i was thinking about it
and when i was thinking about these
other sort of experiences that i was
talking to you about
um the more i was starting to think
maybe the reality of the story is the
two-dimensional creatures are actually
three-dimensional
and um that they're well it's maybe
their soul or their mind or whatever
is the thing that grows up and but
because it's their mind or their soul
and their they see themselves as 2d
creatures they
they don't see that and um so
so making the analogy now over to the
human being
the way i sort of conceptualize the
human being and the relation between
body and soul is this extra dimensional
connection
and that there is another direction
that's not up down left right
um but there's an element of the body
that grows
in this other direction and i
i sort of connected it to the brain as
well in the same way that you were
saying that
a lot of the energy that goes it goes to
your brain
and this is true and it also helps to
sort of make sense of this idea of these
connections that you can get with people
where when you're thinking about them
they seem to know you're thinking about
them and they can get in touch with you
or
when i was when i mentioned the story
about me um
[Music]
talking about um
the when's your earliest memory like i
was trying to visualize and
like i couldn't get this story out of my
head how if
my mind was growing in this other
direction and he was to see
my thought how how would he be able to
recognize that as mine
there would be no way and um
so when you were talking there about
like this excess of energy
it sort of links there to this idea
because i i do think
because you you are right if you have
too much of something if you don't do
something to vent it you know like
the same way with the pot if you don't
like let the steam out
the pot is going to explode um and in
the same way if you've got a lot of
pent-up
anger if you don't do something to vent
that
like you say if there's no prior
movement
um consciously then it's going to happen
automatically
and so you'll that'll be like an
outburst and then you're not in control
anymore
yeah exactly um now
it what you're saying there it makes it
the only thing i would sort of
maybe mention on so you refer to energy
within a closed system um
it can neither be created or destroyed
on top of
what's in that system um now how do we
relate that to allah's power like for
example
we would say that creation um
obviously is is created um that the
there's a sort of theological issue you
just need to be a little bit careful of
in regards to
if energy is itself it's possible that
it is
created it's just that we can't add
anything to it yeah we can yeah
yeah um the question is how does that
energy relate
to allah's power because allah is
obviously eternal and his power is um
eternal with him um and so that there is
this
eternal power and energy
is sometimes described as power as well
it's just you know the potential for
something um for work
but so there's just a thin line there
that just i guess
we can think about it and maybe talk
about it another time but just um
i would be careful of referring to
energy something that
you know the way you would it is um yeah
but yeah no but were you saying that i
would say obviously like
quick disclaimer guys if whatever i'm
saying it doesn't i'm not intending to
you know contradict any you know
authentic ideas or like yeah
i don't think about that yeah and i
never just it's just the way our
anecdotal
i guess limited subjective experience to
try to rationalize and like
explain why things are the way they are
yeah and like
it's again it can only it could it could
be a placebo who knows but
it's worked for us talk to a lot of
people hamdulillah so yeah so it's
pragmatic in that sense didn't it
so yeah definitely and but the thing is
is it does
what you say is something that sort of
connects so a few ideas that i've been
running around in my head
and um i would because
the question here with regards to a lot
of these things that we refer to as sort
of
mental illnesses is a question of what
we consider to be normal or abnormal
um and a lot of the time it's like well
who's deciding what's
abnormal exactly and you know
especially with today's age and of
obsession of sort of writing things down
categorizing it putting everything into
specific boxes and calling things like
illnesses like my brother
he was someone who was my mum was told
he had adhd
and they wanted to um hop him up on
ritalin or whatever it is they give
the kids and um when they told my mum
she was just like auntie this sort of
mentality completely unbelievable
because
um he is a normal guy he was just
someone who had like you were describing
that like a lot of energy
and he he needed ways of venting that
and
the environment that he was in just
wasn't allowing that
means he's a hunter trait yeah yeah yeah
it's actually a gift you know yeah yeah
but it makes it seem like it's not
yeah it's like um if you put
like if you're if you're judging a fish
based on its ability to climb a tree
yeah or flag yeah then it'll be a
useless fish
then the person that's making the
mistake here is the
the the one trying to get what something
like it's a qualification
in its own particular nature would
thrive and then trying to take it out of
that
like the classroom is for a very
particular kind of person
like you can't expect everyone to thrive
in that environment
um and but just simply because they
don't thrive in that particular
environment it doesn't mean they've
they're a failure or that they're you
know that there's something wrong with
them
half of the time it's just the case of
like how we've understood
how an upbringing should take place and
well i feel that because because me and
ana
the amount of times we got like our
parents called for just not being in our
seat
yeah you know so if
and the question here is like is it
really really reasonable to expect
every single child to have to go through
this sort of factory line
setting where like the only thing
everyone has in common
is their date of birth their date of
manufacture
they go through the years like a
conveyor belt
and through this generalized method of
study
where all kids are just sort of treated
the same everyone has to sit down in
this classroom
for x amount of days maybe there's one
lesson a week which we'll call
physical education which is an hour
if that where they're doing something
active
and then for the rest of it we're
expecting them to sit down listen to
people that are
what 50 to 60 70 of the time boring
monotone voices hate their job
in a state of repetitive they're
underpaid they're overworked
you know like and what you want the kids
to listen to this man
yeah it's uh it's not strange to think
that
certain people with excess of energy
here
wouldn't um thrive in that particular
kind of environment
but then you get my brother you put him
into a rugby team and he was an
absolute monster and he was like
charging through kids
and uh breaking arms and like
like in that environment he thrived and
in that other he didn't
and they couldn't really see that yeah
they got the problem on him and
diagnosed it as an illness
100 man i was just going to add that
that that whole cliche that we
were brought up with the guy who's was
stupid
you know but they're like he has bad
grades but like he's good at gym
and then you know everyone's like oh it
doesn't matter you're good at gym that's
not what really matters what really
matters matters math and like science
like
what if that's just not for him right
there's this whole standardized system
of
of baseless i guess standards because
it shouldn't relate to everyone right we
live in a one-size-fits-all society
well it's because it's effective um
effective in the sense that it's like if
you had a system that was
um taking every individual into account
and trying to play on the strengths of
people and didn't just look at them in
terms of oh well he was born in
you know 1989 or 19 whatever
um that's that takes a lot
of energy it takes a lot of time it
takes a lot of
resources in order to build a system
that does that
it's a lot more effective in terms of
costs
and effort and energy to just make this
sort of standardized system
that treats children like products on a
conveyor belt
in a factory because the whole system
itself is built on this sort of
um you know the industrial factory lines
setting
is it a mass influence too yeah yeah
exactly um
and so you just put things through this
system and it comes out the other end
and you've got this like
prepared individual and those who don't
happen to fit
very well with that system are just sort
of discarded to the sideline and
considered them
ineffective or problematic like this
yeah but it's like you know somebody
like let's say for example like my
brother if you'd maybe found
him a an apprenticeship and put him into
sort of like
you know manual labor instead of through
this high school system
and maybe obviously the certain things
are important say there was
like an hour or two hours a day that was
set aside
for learning other subjects like maths
and english or science
um maybe that would have been a lot more
effective having him work
hands-on you know getting sweaty you
know using
strength and you know having to engage
with things rather than just
like sit there and think about all these
abstract
notions and looking at writing on a on a
whiteboard but
like getting his hands dirty that maybe
that would have been
like a million times it's not like he's
doing bad for himself now i'm
he's got his own like uh food business
and he's running
you know he's doing things with his
hands let's see exactly yeah
he's uh and he's thriving in it he's
doing really well
um but yeah and it's just yeah no i i
agree with you
his his personality type or just i guess
just
even his biochemistry it's more like a
kinesthetic learner
i mean they're not the typical student
you know in a in a classroom setting
it's not going to be yeah
they they work better with like hands-on
there's there's people with adhd
they they comprise of the overwhelming
amount of people in trades
right and like skills and there's people
that are like more like
it starts to sound just like a
personality type than a disease isn't it
it's like
yeah exactly and that's all it is
bro if allah made us you know in all
these different ways
it's not because i don't know but
society they don't have islam right so
yeah any any more uh thoughts on your
mind before we wrap this one up
yes uh so i just wanted to sort of bring
it back so we were talking about drugs
before
perfect i was telling people about um
the experiences that i've had on them
etc
so i just want to really like put an
emphasis on here
um i don't want to make it seem like i
was
um beautifying that at all because it
really isn't it's an ugly scene
um and it's one of the
i would say major contributing factors
to a lot of the problems that we're
having
um on earth today and um
like allah in the quran when he talks
about alcohol
he says there may be some benefits in it
but it's negatives
outweigh and he's talking here about
intoxic intoxicants
he says there may be there may be
benefits but it's negatives outweigh
the benefits and so you should avoid it
now
there is something similar here with
things like drugs so you know there are
things that
um you can talk about that are called
positive experiences but the negatives
completely outweigh them the addictive
behavior that
sort of comes carried along with that um
the
you know the the negative consequences
that it has on things like your
personality
on um the way you you deal with the
world
and the the impacts it can have
on the widest side bro yeah and yeah on
your wallet and
but on the community it's like like my
dad
him dabbling in drugs um
one thing yeah took a huge toll on his
wallet
um he struggled to keep a job um
he got into things like stealing in
order to make up
the funds that he didn't have because he
was spending it on
drugs um it you know had a massive
impact on his family it killed him in
the end
you know his relationship with his wife
with his children was
um you know that affected
heavily because of that and i i see the
same thing happening with a lot of my
friends so
not everyone's on heroin some people do
cocaine and you see
a similar thing it's money it's
addictive it
has these horrible impacts on things
like their behavior
their personality um things like cocaine
cause people to become like egomaniacs
almost especially when they're on it
um and then these other drugs like even
the ones that i was mentioning weed
there's huge impacts and there's always
going to be the exception to the case
there's you know you're going to get
your joel rogers like then i'm you know
a millionaire look at me
you know i'm healthy and i go fighting
and i do this and i smell weed it's like
yeah but bro you're like
a tiny exception to the rule like
the majority of people when they're
young and they get on this sort of stuff
they they have increased chances of
things like
um you know paranoias and schizophrenia
and things like this
and there seems to at least be some sort
of
correlation here between certain types
of behavior
being accentuated when you take these
kind of things and
then they're really not necessary now
they say sometimes and this is a common
mantra in western society that
oh you need to let them make their own
mistakes no you don't
you don't need to make your own mistakes
a wise man can learn from the mistakes
of someone else
now you can get an insight into the
the positives of these things by hearing
about other people's experiences
and about what they took from that that
doesn't mean you have to experience that
yourself
you don't have to murder someone
and to go through the profound guilt and
shame that might be associated
with the realization that what you've
done is wrong in order to understand
the wisdom behind the rule that you
shouldn't murder people
like yes i can guarantee that if you did
it
and felt all the negative impacts that
there would be
a lot of lessons to be learned from that
but it doesn't follow that you need to
that everyone needs to make that mistake
it's the same things like
drugs psychedelics and stuff like that
there are mad experiences
that you can have on these things some
of them can be incredibly interesting
some of them can
be pleasurable some of them can be um
insightful but it's you know
it doesn't follow from that that you
need to have these things as well and
that you
you need to come out of that that um in
order to abstract whatever wisdom there
may
be within that and there's a warning as
well be wary of
wisdom that's unearned that's like the
buddhist call right
yeah don't be aware of unearned wisdom
and with
these drugs and things like that you get
these mad little insights
um and but it's not the only way to
achieve these insights
there are alternative methods and
you know that that is through things
like reading like picking up books
like even just reading the accounts of
people that have gone through this
you you can abstract wisdom from these
experiences
that other people have had you don't you
know subhanallah we live in a world
where
people are taking this all over the
place and they're writing about their
experiences they're doing youtube videos
and their experiences
you don't need to go through that in
order to
whatever wisdom there may be in that to
have to take from it
um you know you know you don't need to
become an alcoholic
to figure out why being alcoholics are
bad um
and yeah and it's just you know you can
get the best of both worlds by not doing
it and just
studying that kind of stuff like you can
like listen to today's
discussion um that we've had i'm below
it's been a
really interesting one um but you know
in inshallah
you maybe can have taken something from
my telling you about my experiences with
it
um and maybe inshallah you can
understand why you don't need
to go down the route having to take
these things as well
forget that fomo you know the fear of
missing out crap
there's you know enough people
that savannah i'm trying to think now
about the times that i've
peer pressured people into taking drugs
bro
don't get me started yeah the guilt that
i have now
thinking back like these innocent souls
that just had never touched weed never
know and i beautified it to them and
took them on this journey and like
and i made it look nice and i painted it
in all sorts of pretty things and
you know yeah i mean i mean and like i
was so
familiar with that experience
that i i was very good at bringing
people into it that had never done it
before and making it an amazing thing
making it an enjoyable experience for
them by like
you know knowing what sort of things
cause negative
reactions and stuff like that and how to
facilitate a good
time um but like i regret that so much
now
because it's like it's an it was an
act for the most part it's like yeah in
certain environments
in certain conditions in certain
contexts i can take you on this sort of
particular kind of journey
but when things get dark and this
thing's a part of your life
this thing doesn't help overcome man
this thing doesn't help you to
take the steps that you need in order to
be able to overcome certain
um problems certain issues in life
um and so yeah i don't mean to sound
like i'm beautifying it oh the blah it's
the complete opposite
i'm trying to give you an insight into
something so that you don't have to go
and take it yourself
um and i really do want to emphasize
that these things are incredibly
dangerous
um and just not worth the time effort
and money that you're going to end up
investing in it if you do ever start to
double in it um
it's you know islam is a shield for the
believer
and you like just the same as interest
and things like that yeah if you took
out a loan
with interest maybe you could to start a
business and become a millionaire
maybe there's lots of benefits that
could come out of that um
but you know there's always exceptions
to these rules
and you're not guaranteed to be someone
who has
this amazing experience out of it it's
incredibly dangerous and the chances are
more likely the case
you're going to be someone who ends up
at the the butt end
of the the you know the realm of
possible experience
um and it's just really not worth that
risk and
the consequences that it has on the
people around you
um is you know terrible like
my dad made little decisions to start
taking certain kind of drugs
um eventually it killed him and it had a
huge impact on his three children
on the woman that he loved um
on his family you know his dad was still
alive when he passed his brother
his sisters his cousins you know all
those people around him that loved him
um why because he wanted to dabble in
something and he didn't see anything
wrong
and the people around him beautified it
and then subhana
that's had a huge impact on the life of
everyone who cared for him
um so it's just not worth the risk and
like i say you can
abstract whatever wisdom is there
potentially from just reading about it
um you don't need to take it yeah i just
wanted to end on that because it felt
like important and
i didn't want it
for all the wisdom all the insight all
these these golden nuggets of just
wisdom that
even i'm i've benefited so much man
that's why i wasn't talking too much in
this episode
and especially the last one we did with
you because yeah sorry i do
ramble i i love learning bro i'm awful
with that
yeah i didn't feel that one bit like i
feel like teachers and props around the
world because i'm not really engaged but
i felt very engaged on the left i need
to learn to talk less though
and i keep forgetting and then just
going on these huge 10-hour
for spiels me on it's been a pleasure
it's
a weird dynamic to going from watching
your podcast to being on it
so uh thank you for inviting me it's
been a pleasure talking to both you and
ramy
i think that i think the audience should
look forward to uh the tap and t3m
collab in sha allah yeah i look forward
to that we need to um
finish that discussion i think that yeah
for sure
we're good this week next week too so
we'll make it happen inshallah
insha allah but yeah for the time man
grant you a long successful life
just continuing to influence a lot of
people keep doing your work being a
great father
man if there's anything else just don't
hesitate to let me know yeah
bro stay in touch
take care first and foremost the prophet
salallahu
he said that basically when a group of
companions came to him and asked you
know we're dealing with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said
that this is good news this is good news
and obviously it's very it sounds upsy
moronic how is
you know big doubts in faith good news
in the process
he said it's a sign of high iman think
about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]